Speaker 1: Donald Trump looks visibly scared in
a new video wherein he demands cognitive tests
for other elected officials. This is completely
and totally bonkers. And what's fascinating is,
in a way, he's agreeing with Nikki Haley
in that there should be cognitive tests
for elected officials, But there is absolutely
seemingly no understanding on Trump's behalf
that many of the people calling for the tests are
calling for them because they don't think Trump
would pass them. Let's take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: In my mind, anybody running for the
office of president of the United States
should agree to take a full and complete
mental competency test simultaneously or before
with the announcement that he or she is running
and likewise, but to a somewhat lesser extent
agree to a test which would prove that you are
physically capable of doing the job as president.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Now understand, in Trump's mind
he thinks that this full and comprehensive test
would be the Montreal Cognitive Assessment,
where you identify a giraffe and draw arrows
on a clock and remember five words man, woman,
person, camera, TV famously were Trump's
examples. But that is not a full assessment,
I hate to tell you. That is like a dementia and
stroke screening, brain injury screening. Anyway,
let's continue being outstanding.
Speaker 4: President requires great
mental acuity and physical stamina and strength.
If you don't have these qualities or traits,
it is likely that you will not
succeed and you will disappoint.
The entire world, let alone our own country.
Speaker 1: And that's what happened under Trump.
Interestingly enough, this is like a very accurate
diagnosis of exactly what happened. Trump couldn't
do it, and everybody was indeed disappointed.
Speaker 4: We need to make America great again.
Take a competency test. Let's see whether
or not these people that are running for
office are competent. I took the
test two years ago and I want to
take it again because I think I'd even do better.
Speaker 1: He aced it, but he would do better. He
would get like it's like getting a 4.4 GPA.
Speaker 4: But he running for president,
we're 350 million people are relying on you.
They're relying on your brain. They're relying
on your competence. I think taking a
competency test would be a good thing.
There you go. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Wow. Just
really incredible, incredible stuff. And then also
really weird when it comes to videos released by
Trump. He prays he is becoming so obsessed with
Ron DeSantis that he actually in this video,
praises Democrat Charlie Crist and says Florida's
been good from before DeSantis. This is a very
interesting approach he's taking.
Speaker 4:
For those of you that didn't notice, Florida was
doing great long before Ron DeSantis got here.
Speaker 1: I can't deal with the Desanctis
thing. I can't tell if DeSantis is that Trump
messed up saying too sanctimonious once.
And so now he's he's sticking with the
Sanctus. But the serious use of that is crazy.
Speaker 4: People are fleeing from New York to
Florida and other places, right? Because
of high taxes and out of control crime,
It's really bad. Yeah. Not because of
the governor. Thank you, Mr. President,
for doing that. But it's not because of the
governor. Florida was doing fantastically.
You had a governor named Rick Scott who did a
very good job. Even Charlie Crist, a Democrat,
did a good job. And he had very good numbers.
Sunshine and ocean are very alluring. It's
not too hard to work.
Speaker 1: It's like
a travel video promo, those factors.
Speaker 4: So just remember, Florida was doing
really well long before Ron DeSantis got there.
Speaker 1: There you go. A message from your
president, Donald J. Trump. Listen,
the one big takeaway there is
for Trump to be willing to praise a Democratic
Florida governor, Charlie Crist. He must be really
desperate to attack Desanctis in any way possible.
And I can only imagine if DeSantis does run how
ugly this is going to get. Now, over the last 24
hours, I received a few emails from people, people
in the audience who said, You know, David, I'm
actually wondering, is DeSantis setting himself
up to run in 2028? Because DeSantis may genuinely
not want this ugly primary against Trump. Trump's
not going to run in 2028 no matter what either.
He'll have been president for four more years and
that'll be it, or he'll lose and he'll be 82
or however old he would be then. And he's not
going to run then. The way to do it would be for
DeSantis to politely bow out or just not run and
then be ready to go in 2028. DeSantis would be
like 48 years old at the time, and that might be
the absolute best way to go. It's an interesting
idea. It is a quite an interesting idea. I just
don't know if DeSantis is going to be able to
get away from the polling numbers that he has,
despite the fact that he has he's not even
running yet. So we're going to follow it. We
will see. But Trump highly, highly triggered by
DeSantis mere existence in the state of Florida.